welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel studios just revealed
and confirmed 16 major titles coming to
disney plus in the next couple years
some of these we already knew about but
we just learned about even more like
agatha house of harkness echo marvel
zombies spider-man freshman year x-men
97 all these are having our minds
zipping through endless possibilities
like dr freaking strange now of these i
am definitely most excited about house
of harkness i'll explain why in a bit
but first we gotta go through all of
these to explain marvel's release
timeline and overall streaming content
plan because i am so pumped for this
let's start with hawkeye the first two
episodes are gonna come out november
24th thanksgiving week gonna be
following clint barton hawkeye and his
new trainee kate bishop haley steinfeld
as they face off against the tracksuit
mafia these guys always say bro bro
show's also going to feature vera
farmiga as kate's mother eleanor bishop
and jack dukane i think we can assume
it's gonna set up the young avengers in
the mcu of which kate bishop hawkeye is
a big part of new rockstar is going to
be covering hawkeye every week with
inside marvel after shows and of course
scene by scene breakdowns of all the
easter eggs you missed disney plus they
showed us some awesome new footage from
this show the scene where they flee the
tracksuit mafia while stealing a car
taken directly from the matt fraction
david aha comics we hear the nutcracker
music and they have this awesome
unbroken rotating tracking shot in the
car with director rhys thomas looking
like he's paying direct homage to
alfonso cuaron's amazing shot and
children of men i'm so so excited to see
this series but moving on to the big
headline from today moon night coming
soon hopefully early 2022 starring oscar
isaac as mark spector who gets possessed
by the egyptian moon deity of konshu
giving him supernatural abilities
connected to the lunar cycle but all
depicted in the form of dissociative
identity disorder gonna be an amazing
point of view show oscar isaac's gonna
crush this ethan hawk is gonna be
playing an unknown villain in it gasper
uliel is gonna be playing midnight man
and i'm super excited to see how moon
knight can connect to characters like
blade and black knight dane whitman in a
possible midnight sun series that could
also bring in characters like ghost
rider and mephisto into the mcu
potentially link up with agatha harkness
and house of harkness then of course
there's she-hulk starring tatiana
maslany as jennifer walters pro attorney
and cousin of bruce banner who somehow
is gonna get powered up into she-hulk
who is an amazing character marvel
comics member of the fantastic four
associate of the avengers mark ruffalo
is going to return in the series both in
his smart hulk form and in his human
form that we saw in the shang chi post
credits scene however he reverted back
to human form probably shows that he has
mastery over when he transforms into
hulk which is how he's going to help his
cousin jennifer power up into this form
but in the marvel comics she-hulk tends
to stay in her green form throughout her
normal life it's gonna be a 10-episode
legal comedy and tim roth as abomination
is gonna return in this show we saw him
in chiang chi as well making me think
everything that's going on with thaddeus
ross and val putting together a dark
avengers or a thunderbolts team with
elena bulova john walker potentially
abomination as well could all play into
this series but jamila jamil is going to
be playing mary mcferrin aka titania who
was turned into a superhero by dr doom
now will dr doom play into this series
we'll see might be a little early for it
for me it's never too soon to bring dr
doom into the mcu now confirm for summer
2022 is miss marvel starring iman
villani as kamala khan a muslim
pakistani american teenager living in
new jersey who idolizes characters like
harold danvers captain marvel who seems
like from this trailer footage is gonna
get hit by a similar blast of cosmic
radiation that we saw carol danvers get
hit with and monica rambo go through as
she passed through the hex wall of west
view in wandavision so all three of
these women are going to come together
in the marvel's film captain marvel 2
coming february 2023 but this series is
gonna be an origin story for kamala khan
in the comics she gets hit by a terrigen
mist which is how inhumans get formed
but i'm less confident that the mcu is
gonna bring back the inhuman mythology
and instead might make kamala khan a
mutant something i go into in the video
on that but in the comics she has the
power to embiggen her fists her limbs to
stretch out kind of like reed richards
mr fantastic but it looks like on this
show they're gonna be dialing that back
and instead reframe her powers as a kind
of like green lantern style genie magic
where she can project a larger fist that
is made of that cosmic radiation the
next title we know of is i am groot so
it's gonna be kind of like a baby groot
origin story the title card shows up
with like leafy muscles and a crazy
leafy hairdo genealogically speaking
groot is a flora colossi from planet x
there are a lot of these tree-like
beings so this may be an origin story
that shows him with his family before he
discovered his new family with the
guardians of the galaxy and specifically
with rocket i would love to see an
episode where baby groot first meets
rocket because i've always speculated
that there could be some kind of like
divine significance to groot with his
ability to regenerate but not keep his
memories and in fact i've always
wondered if this whole embers of the
universe that was introduced in episode
2 of what if could be rooted in what
groot is made out of in the mcu at least
following that we'll have a guardians of
the galaxy holiday special from james
gunn directly that is going to be canon
in a way that the star wars holiday
special from the 70s is technically
canon as well because it was the first
appearance of boba fett in any star wars
property so who knows what debuts will
come in this guardians of the galaxy
holiday special perhaps the debut of
will polter's adam warlock that dude by
the way got checked but then we got a
reminder something we already knew that
what if season two is coming we can
assume that it's gonna explore the
consequences of the watchers actions in
the final episodes of what if season one
like he had this oath that he broke are
there gonna be other watchers who come
to punish him for that are other big
cosmic forces like galactus gonna drop
in we got a little galactus cameo there
where giant ultron infinity just took a
bite into a galaxy like a donut we also
are confirmed to have another captain
carter episode the showrunner said that
she's gonna be a focal character of the
whole series the post-credits scene of
season one showed captain carter and
black widow on the lumerian star finding
steve rogers hydra stomper armor
suggested have steven's side but in this
reality will steve have been corrupted
by hydra as part of a winter soldier
program then we got confirmation of a
new series we didn't know what's gonna
be happening echo starring alaqua cox
who plays maya lopez aka echo in hawkeye
she is a deaf superhero with the ability
to mirror combat moves kind of like what
taskmaster was supposed to be in black
widow my lopez's father worked for
kingpin in the comics and was actually
killed by kingpin a lot of the criminal
entities we're going to see in hawkeye
actually do work for kingpin in the
comics it's a great opportunity to bring
in wilson fisk in the mcu in the show
hopefully we'll see that in hawkeye and
if not hawkeye in ecco which is going to
be a spin-off and i think we can all
hope be kind of like a daredevil season
4. we need matthew murdock in the mcu
echo would be a great opportunity to do
that now if you have someone on your
holiday shopping list that's hard to
shop for consider getting them a gift
card for a personalized wine selection
from bright sellers that's of course
assuming it's not like your 10 year old
nephew get him a video game but thanks
to bright sellers for sponsoring this
video i love drinking wine much more
than i love picking wine out well bright
cellars does that for me and they do a
really good job of it they use a quiz to
determine your taste preferences and
then they show you a list of the top six
wines that you're most likely to enjoy
from around the world and if you like
your recommendations and you want to try
them they'll ship them straight to your
door and they educate you about wine
along the way with their wine education
cards that have helpful info like tasty
notes and pairing recommendations
check it out so here's the box i got
this month
oh baby ooh check it out so i've gotten
this one before this is the folk and
fable to red zinfandel already jammy and
spicy the zinfandel spends three months
ago bourbon barrels adding even more to
those qualities with notes of stewed
fruits toasted caramel and vanilla i
like all those things
look i've received a bunch of boxes from
bright cellars over the past year and
based on my feedback they have adjusted
the wines that they send me sometimes i
want to try something again sometimes
they send me new stuff i always love
this election though and you can
celebrate cyber monday with an exclusive
deal get sixty percent off your first
four bottle box plus a bonus bottle of
wine and a corkscrew for just thirty
dollars plus shipping and handling
that's 108 value for just 30 dollars so
happy holidays and to all some good wine
we also got a tease of loki season two i
think this is going to be coming out
right before ant-man the wasp
quantomania which is going to be july
2023 and in the second season we're
definitely gonna see more of kang the
conqueror who in the new reality that
loki ends up in the season finale has
warped even the tva something that we
thought was neutral ground so that a
massive statue of kang has replaced the
statue of the timekeepers we also last
saw sylvie in the citadel at the end of
time after slaying he who remains and
she and loki seem to be now star-crossed
lovers in separate realities altogether
so i think the world building is gonna
continue in different vectors all
together giving us more insight into
where exactly the tba is and what parts
of reality kang has already warped kang
remains the most fascinating villain
ahead in the mcu someone who ties in
with the fantastic four and the young
avengers then interesting announcement
x-men 97 which is gonna be a
continuation of the amazing fox 90s
animated series that i grew up with my
first access point to how amazing the
marvel world is they're using the same
character designs it's gonna be coming
in 2023 with a lot of the same voice
casts coming back from the 90s series
along with new voices so the original
series ran from 1992 to 1997 on fox
animation this is going to be picking up
right where that left off i mean this
series was so crucial to everything we
love about the mcu now because it
directly inspired the 2000 x-men film
that launched the creators of hugh
jackman and so many others including
kevin feige who is an associate producer
on that film and that launched his
career to the trajectory where he could
give us the mcu as we know and love it
now and then another animated series
spider-man freshman year fascinating
looks like it's gonna be animated in the
style of the 60s comic books the classic
spider-man from the old days it has yet
to be seen how connected to the mcu
canon this will be because it's a big
deal to have spider-man which is still a
sony property on disney plus this is
going to be run by jeff trammell who is
a writer and actor in the cartoon
network series craig of the creek so i'm
excited to see what comes from this but
we also got a reminder that ironheart is
coming starring dominique thorne as riri
williams an mit student who idolizes
tony stark and then engineers her own
iron man armor to carry his legacy
actually riri williams is expected to
first appear in black panther wakanda
forever if that movie can ever come out
because i know there's a lot of drama on
production there i've always speculated
that rio williams could have been one of
those students at mit when stark did the
speech there in civil war which could be
a fun scene to revisit like tony stark
and mysterio quinton beck and riri
williams could have all been in the same
room at the same time and this title
card design looks like it's a heart that
has been welded together with each
letter having similar welding aesthetics
to it i would love if this show includes
a shot of just riri williams just like
tony stark hammering away at her armor
okay but then the big title i'm most
excited about agatha house of harkness
now we did learn that catherine han as
zack of the harness was getting her own
spin-off now we know the title is house
of harkness i don't think i'm reading
too much into it to say the house of
structure is gotta be important wordplay
given all the parallels in wanda vision
and probably with the multiverse of
madness to the house of m events in the
marvel comics well no more for sure
after a trailer for multiverse of
madness and after that movie comes out
in may 2022 but if multiverse of madness
is house of m this show being called
house of harkness is gonna give us our
own unique look at agatha harkness's
inner world because at the end of wanda
vision wanda left her in that weird
creepy trance it was suggested that the
rest of the west view hex faded away
after the final battle of wandavision
but we don't know exactly what happened
to agatha suggested that she was left in
that kind of trance which is kind of a
creepy thing for wanda to do to her now
coming out of one division we know that
agatha for years was trying to be the
alpha witch herself she absorbed all the
powers of her coven that tried to burn
her at the stake for bypassing the
sorcery that was she supposed to limit
herself to reading the dark hole and
while my mephisto theories for one
division ended up not coming true it
still could very well be the case that
agatha harkness has some off-screen
relationship with mephisto we even
learned about the deleted scene from
monovision where her rabbit senior
scratchy was going to be revealed as a
demon in disguise her familiar who
chased those kids around the dungeon so
jack schaefer is returning as show
runner on the series this is going to be
very much a one division season two and
everything dark horror themed
supernatural occult in the mcu going
forward is gonna be rooted in this show
we also got a reminder that armor wars
is coming this is gonna be roadie's next
appearance in the mcu following the
falcon the winter soldier cameo where he
told sam wilson we'll be in touch
meaning maybe captain america sam could
come back in this series it's also
implied that riri williams ironheart
could cross in as well because this
series is gonna be following the theme
of what happens if tony stark's tech
gets in the wrong hands which i would
argue is a theme of like i don't know 18
out of 24 mcu movies that we know of
already but specifically there's a
question of nanotech introduced in
avengers infinity war some believe that
doc ock could be using nanotech in his
arms in spiderman no way home nanotech
is kind of like a godly powerful form of
technology that tony stark and
spider-man seem to have unique access to
i guess along with pepper potts as we
saw in the in-game final battle so
nanotech would be like an interesting
virus if it's in the wrong hands i would
love to see arnhem zola show up in this
show seeing how in the animated what if
it was implied that there was a version
of zola in that siberian hydra base
could that also be the case in live
action mcu and zola is still out there
speaking of what if we learned that
marvel zombies is getting its own
spin-off we don't know if it's gonna be
a direct spin-off from what if but it
looks like it's gonna spend more time
embracing the robert kirkman comic
series that the marvel zombies episode
of what if didn't spend a lot of time
adapting directly but in the kirkman
comics this virus's origin is crazy it
comes from an alternate reality it's
called the hunger it goes from reality
to reality the fantastic four get
involved galactus gets involved so the
fact that this episode ended with zombie
thanos having five out of six stones
potentially getting the sixth stone this
virus could jump from reality to reality
and we could get the true marvel zombies
storyline that we got in the comics and
what if director brian andrews is
directing this series and lastly a
reminder of the secret invasion
storyline coming we got a brief shot of
nick fury no eye patch is this nick fury
is this taylos who is impersonating him
in spider-man far from home i'm so
pumped for this this cast is gonna be
crazy we know ben mendelson is coming
back they're gonna have olivia coleman
in this show christopher mcdonald's
gonna be in the show king's leap and a
deer and it's going to be asking the
question of who do you trust who in the
mcu that we have trusted all this time
is who we thought they were has actually
been a scroll imposter at the top of my
list are hank pym and karoon from
eternals but i'll be making plenty of
future scroll search videos in the days
weeks and months and maybe years ahead
so there you go 16 new titles coming to
disney plus hopefully all these will
come out by the end of 2023 because i
need my weekly marvel content to keep me
a happy boy let me know what title
you're most excited about and you can
support this channel by checking out our
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of all this stuff we got a
lot to break down in the next two years
and i can't wait to join you guys to
watch all of it thanks for watching this
see you next time bye
[Music]
you